explorers opened up the world all around these fearless men they succeeded in doing well in all
hemispheres their great audacity made us an offering of the earth yes these knights i tell
you have never wavered the explorers have never weakened nothing can stop them neither wind nor
storm these men of heart no for the backdrop of the canvas the dream of advancing is crazy and
without worrying about jealousy it sails forward the explorers sailed valiantly across the oceans
their navigators with hearts that were in fact brave and the storms their little black shells
were truly no match and on the raging waves their temerity was clearly demonstrated the explorers
always revealed new things to us with beauty rejected fear refused all fear of adventures
in order to return this money and offer the sum to souls children this concludes the chronicle of
those who have explored our planet earth i have already told you many stories including those of
the beginning of our world. That's about 15 billion years. Before that, well, no one knows
anything. After that, after that, it would take another 10 billion years for this matter,
at a temperature of billions of degrees, to take shape and form our Earth. Billion more years.
Barely 10 meters of a century for the first cell, the source of all life, to appear. It is indeed
the source of all life. You, me and all the others. We descend from this stardust that ended
up organizing itself into this. It is our ancestors, or if you prefer, the first link in a chain that
will lead to all life, including man. We descend from stardust. How pretty.
Indeed, after all, everything happened very quickly, barely a few million centuries. The
flagellates, the vulvox, the trilobites. It took another 4 billion years for the first amphibian to
set foot on the ground. And this one would become a dinosaur, yes. Probably a meteorite that hit the
Earth. In any case, the dinosaurs would disappear in this cataclysm to make way for the first of
the same level. The Triconodon, the Smilotect, the Pliopithecus, the Proconsul, the Pre-Australopitae,
the Australopithecus, the Robustus, the Homoilus, the Picatoporhomoris, the Sonant, the Khan,
Neanderthal, and Cro-Magnon, Modern Man. This man would show himself eager to leave his mark on
the world. His achievements. Where's they the beginning of? Man also wanted to go further and
further, faster and faster. Oh no no no. Stop. That's enough. Let's not go any further. We'll
talk about that later. Man also wanted greater comfort. A comfort that at the beginning of its
history was completely non-existent. I'm going into a room. Oh, of course. This seems perfectly
normal to you, huh? A watch, printing, electricity, the telephone, university, television, and the
internet or your daily life. But it wasn't always like this. And I've explained to you how discoverers
have changed our lives. Urik, Rika, I've found a thousand discoveries. Gutenberg and the EVU.
And yet, Galileo, the Earth is no longer the center of the universe, Newton and universal
gravitation. Oh, Darwin, man descends from the breast. Edison, the telegraph, the phonogram,
the light bulb, cinema, Marconi, the first connections through others. And as I told you,
man wants to go faster, further. Yes, yes, we'll talk about that later. So I was saying, yes,
I was saying that in the past, to help you understand the relative place occupied by our
earth, so tiny in the universe, I took you to explore the cosmos. We also explored man,
the measure of all things, and observed the functioning of his body through the universe
of the infinitesimals of his organism. And here we are today with these men who have wanted to
explore the world since the dawn of our history. Gregors and Phoenicians circumnavigated Africa
and reached the polar regions. Alexander the Great went as far as the Indies, the Vikings
reached America. Marco Polo went as far as China. The Chinese Zong ventured as far as Africa.
Christopher Columbus and the Pinson brothers discovered America. In a handful of centuries,
Man would explore his planet in all its latitudes, from the bottom to the top.
James C., Stanley and Livingstone, Tyler and Tencel at the summit of the Vrest.
But man who has traveled his planet, adorned it with his knowledge, now believes he has it, while he mistreats it, always wanting more and more, without respecting it.
. In some industrialized regions, rivers dump a ton of waste per capita per day into the sea.
A ton, can you imagine?
Not gay.
ah the result is all sorts of diseases a reduction in our life expectancy but who cares too many
interests are at stake and what happens to man what happens to life in all this but maestro let's
not say that the earth is already populated enough as it is but that's no reason to threaten the
lives of its inhabitants well here i am going to talk to you about demography in the beginning
five billion years ago there were of course no humans on the planet 15 million centuries later
here came the amoeba. Another 32 million centuries for Homo erectus to appear.
There will be about 1 million. Another 30 million centuries and here are our ancestors,
the Cro-Magnons. There will be a few million, at least that's what we think.
Year 0, the Earth has 250 million inhabitants. 15 centuries later, 500 million people.
So they have doubled in 1500 years. 4 centuries later, there are 2 billion.
The world's population has quadrupled in four times less time. Kids, in 1975, this population
has just doubled again. Statistics predict 8 billion people in 2010, and yes, 16 billion in
2045, billion in 2080, 64 billion in 2115, 128 billion in 2150. These prospects are not very good
either. Finally, let's hope that man will come to his senses before then, because even today,
half of the world's population, 3 billion, do not have at least a few small atomic bombs that
will fix everything. This is no joke. Think of the consequences of such a thing, the grief,
the misfortunes, the misery that this cataclysm would cause. In any case, even the peaceful use
of nuclear energy already poses enough problems. It's not very pretty, but don't forget about it.
And what about the waste? Gentlemen specialists, what are you going to do with the waste?
Oh, no problem, dear sir. We'll throw it into the sea. Let's see. We'll bury it, of course.
Well, then, we could send it by rocket into space. Does that suit you?
But let's be serious. This waste will remain harmful for many, many years.
What's he getting involved in? We're the specialists, aren't we?
We know what we're talking about, dear sirs. We're the specialists.
So, we're going to bury it in a very deep geological layer.
Okay.
What kind of geological layer?
Well, that's obvious.
But no, clay and granite are sanitary.
Because of the aluminum silicates they contain, the archer is waterproof.
That's been verified, and because I'm right.
That's it, to end up standing tall and well-shouldered.
In fact, we know very well that some nuclear waste has a lifespan of 150 million years.
As much time as it took to go from dinosaur to other.
All that time, it's true.
It took all that time for the first man to appear.
And yes, maybe even longer.
Remember what I told you earlier.
But it's just that we don't really realize it with these huge numbers and all these endless
COs.
Okay, so, I'm going to try to make this clearer.
Imagine the face of a watch whose 12 hours represent 5 billion years.
The time the Earth has existed.
At zero, hey, the creation of the Earth.
1.5 billion years later, we see the first cell appear.
On our watch, it is then 3.40, the first mollusks at 8 o'clock, when the 111th of the time that goes
from the creation of the earth to today has passed, at 11 o'clock the dinosaurs will appear.
At 11.40, the end of the dinosaurs and the appearance of small rodents. They open the way
to man. 11.55, the Australopithecus. Shut up. 11.59, the mono or modern man. For me, 10 seconds,
that's the year of our health, and it is in these last 10 seconds that the entire history of
man will be recorded because noon is daylight. Okay, is it clearer now? So the evolution of man,
his history ends there. No, my boy, no. We have only lived through 10 seconds of this story.
Man has 12 hours left, or nearly 5 billion years, to spend on Earth. So of course,
he still has time to change. He might be like this, right? Or like this, or even like that.
I wonder how he will be able to keep his balance. And what will this man have left to discover?
Space of course, we will talk about that later. Later, but also his own body, for example his brain, about which he knows very little and which must certainly contain unsuspected resources as interesting to discover as an unknown planet. Man will always have something to explore.
And space, maestro, we know that there are a lot of stars and constellations, but planets with the same climate as Earth. Have we found any? Yes. And on these planets, does life exist? Maestro, will we be able to go there one day?
and live there? Tell us, tell us. Slowly, slowly, not all at once. The last planet in the solar
system, Pluto, was discovered just a few decades ago. So, finding planets in other solar systems
that are billions of times further away is not easy, you know. But then, we haven't found any.
But yes, yes. But just recently, two Swiss astronomers, Coase and Maor, were observing
the constellation PGA. Look, with each turn, the ball pulls my hand back and forth. A star
around a planet does the same. With each turn, it is slightly pulled forward and then back.
It wobbles like this. So there is a planet orbiting the star piece 51. Yes, Maor, and we are going to
announce this discovery. What, what, what's up? I'm busy. I just learned that two Swiss astronomers
have just discovered a planet in the constellation Pegasus. 45 light years away. There's no such
thing as a story. But yes, sir, I checked. Hey, there's another message. French astronauts have
discovered a planet in the star Boris, 52 light years away. Two at once, or almost. Isn't that
fantastic? And for good measure? Professor, professor, come quickly. But it's a planet,
a planet orbiting the clay star 129. It's fantastic. Oh yes, fantastic. Indeed, we hadn't
discovered a planet for so long and suddenly, in the sky, one, then two, then three, then four.
Maestro. How do you see that far? Light years. That's kilometers. Oh yes. Billions of kilometers.
How do you do it? Well, Marconi. It all started with Marconi. Do you remember him? Of course.
H. So we could transmit messages using these electromagnetic waves. As you know,
our space is full of them. Then came the computer. The first computer. It's beautiful,
isn't it, John May? 17,000 lamps, John. 6,000 switches, John. 1,500 relays and 50,000 resistors.
Do you think it'll work, John? I hope so, John. Shall we try? Yes, we'll try, John. The honor is
yours, John. No, the honor is yours, John. First this one, John. No, no, rather this one, John.
It will work in the end, and electronics will help researchers better understand waves.
In a few decades, we will see upheavals that we would never have imagined.
Incredible miniaturization.
Satellites placed in orbit will connect electromagnetic waves.
Finally, here is the Hubble telescope 600 kilometers from Earth.
It doesn't work.
It's blurry.
The mirror must be warped.
To think that it took 10 years to build this telescope, it's going to have to be repaired
in space.
Well, that's going to be tough.
Preparation Complete
You saw the results obtained earlier, the planets discovered.
So now that we know they're there, let's go, okay?
The way you're going.
And how are you going?
Do you want to take the subway?
You don't.
Realize.
Alpha Center, the closest star is more than 4 light years away.
Let's see.
That's 40,000 billion kilometers, my children.
That's really huge.
And even at a speed of 100,000 kilometers per hour.
Yes, I'm 100,000 kilometers per hour.
but we can't go. No, no, no, let's imagine, that would be a journey of, well, more or less,
about 40,000 years. 40,000 years? Yes, and it's 10 times closer than the planet discovered in the
constellation Pegasus. Oh well, we'll never get there. There's no point in even talking about it.
You know, kids, these days, progress is moving so fast. You can see it with the computer.
What would Alexander the Great have thought?
Who took so long to get to India?
Did you see it?
But what is it?
Surely a mirage, Alexander.
It's the effect of fatigue, thirst and heat.
And Christopher Columbus in the company of the Pinson brothers.
Hum.
Please, Lord, give us a little wind.
Do you hear that, mural?
Did you see that?
You have too much imagination, passant.
I didn't see or hear anything.
Imagining with his trusty El Cannon.
My dear, if the wind continues to be so favorable to us,
we'll circle the earth in a year. We just circled the earth in about an hour. That's not bad,
right? So, you see the progress? And there's even better, kids. You probably remember the
first postal service. From Belgium to Austria in three days. Well done. Email from Paris to Beijing.
I'm sending. Done. Receive. Instantaneous transmission. Instantaneous. Well, not quite,
because even waves can't travel faster than light. Light travels at a speed of 300,000 kilometers per
second. So here we're missing a die of a second for the transmission to be instantaneous. And
your story is not funny. No ship will ever be able to travel at the speed of light. It's
impossible. Human history shows us that we should never say never. And as for distances,
take the Orion Nebula. It's 1,500 light years away. So, even at the speed of light, maestro,
it would take us 1,500 years to get there. Not necessarily. Look at this balloon. You might
think that the only way to get from there to there would be to go around it. But in fact, like this,
the arrival point would be very close to the departure point. Well, in space, we call them
black holes. All this is far too complicated for me. As for the ships, I've already told you about
the matter-antimatter ships that would travel at the speed of light. 300,000 kilometers per second,
1 billion kilometer per hour. We also think of the kilometer ships, and those go faster than light
and no one can. But in these ships that go 300 times faster than light, humans will age visibly.
Ah, all the same, to return to those stars that gave birth to man. How nice that would be. Nice,
yes, but very brief. That's why we thought of. Go to the computer and check the status of my
frontal connections. I have a bit of a headache today. Pegas 51 in sight. Perhaps one day a
spaceship sent by man will arrive in sight of a new planet and its explorers will tell us if it
is habitable. Inhabited, probably, but by very different beings. In the meantime, we only have
one planet, one Earth, and it is high time we took much better care of it than we do.
It took the Earth 5 billion years of organic activity to create man and his living conditions.
In 50 million times less time, this man has upset the biological order. He wants to appropriate
everything and he only gives back to the Earth the excrement that he asks it to digest.
This madness of men must stop.
We must find a balance between our needs and the possibilities of our planet.
Harmony must return.
You, the children, will one day be adults and that day you will be able to contribute to safeguarding our beautiful planet.
But I will talk to you about all that another time.
Explorers discovered the world, made the earth round, and you'll still find traces to trace and then offer them to souls as one offers a beautiful woman to you, to us, to me, I believe.
Ah!